you know it's always difficult to know
at any one time as a basic scientist
whether what you're doing at that time
is you know going to have some
monumental significance I'm not sure my
work has monumental significance but it
certainly has been recognized as having
some significance the thing about basic
science is that we and anyone any one
day any one experiment you never really
know you try your best every single day
and I tell my students you know every
day that you that you work in the lab is
a day that you'll never have again and
so think very carefully to do the most
important thing that you can do every
day but the nature of science is is such
that if you're doing real research on
the frontier where nobody's ever been
you know it doesn't always work actually
the hardest thing about being a
scientist is you have to be prepared to
fail most of the time and a Nobel
laureate might be a scientist who fails
only ninety-nine percent of the time
maybe everybody else is a little bit
less luckier or whatever fails
ninety-nine point nine percent of the
time so by definition what you're doing
at any one time is not it's a little
hard to know if it's the most important
on the other hand when it does happen
and it's happened to me actually twice
I've had very special moments and I kind
of understood and everybody around me
kind of understood that it was a special
moment we celebrated some of the basic
discoveries at the time they were made
that the with my co-workers you know
scientists it's also very important for
for students especially to understand
that that that science these days is not
a solo enterprise it's the work of a
team its students professors and we all
contribute not everyone gets recognized
with a Nobel Prize but but but there are
a lot of people who contribute